This is Hannah from Ballerina Farms.
She is a very,
very big influencer.
Millions of followers.
Her and her family live on a farm.
She has eight kids.
She just does a lot of things.
Like I said,
very well known.
Back in August,
I competed at Mrs. America.
I ended up meeting her once.
She seemed totally cool.
She ended up winning the Mrs.
American title.
If you win that,
you go on to compete at Mrs.
World, which is happening right now.
And it just so happens that she had a baby,
like, last week.
Believe it or not,
she is there,
she's competing.
She looks amazing.
And this, of course,
is making a lot of people very, very mad.
I've never seen anything like it.
And yet again,
we are seeing this kind of double standard
that we get from a lot of feminists.
Feminism is super supportive of women
chasing their dreams and doing things,
but only the dreams that they deem appropriate.
Had she had eight abortions
in order to chase her dreams
and in order to be a boss, babe,
uh, these people would be cheering for her right now.
But because she chose to take care of
and love all eight of her babies,
and the fact that she is wildly successful
and prioritizes her family,
it just drives these people insane.
They have a very set ideal of what women
are supposed to do and what women are supposed to be.
They Won't admit it,
but it's true.
It isn't because they are concerned about
her postpartum health
or about her children
or about the well being of her family.
It's because she is continuing to completely destroy
and dismantle the entire modern feminist message.